good morning believe nation today's
message is don't worry about others over
you Carlos Slim Helu success is not
being recognized by others it is not
about an external opinion it is about an
internal state of being
it is the harmony between the soul and
our emotions that are fed by love family
friendship authenticity and honesty the
fullness the fundamental and permanent
values that are far superior to
professional economical social or
political success I think not worrying
about what what others or what others
think of you is like a huge thing for
your life what others think of you or
what you think others think of you can
really put a damper
or or limit you and in what you want to
do so like if for example your thing is
like vlogging and you have to carry a
camera around like you do like to shoot
a vlog and you're thinking about like
what other people on the street are
gonna be like go to this guy with a
camera was he doing you're never gonna
do that right so it same thing goes for
like like being up the gym for example
you go to a public gym and maybe you
think that other people are more fit
than you and you have no place being
there so you're never gonna go to the
gym right so I think you shouldn't
really care about what others think and
that way you can I guess do what you
want to do and express your talents to
their fullest yeah I love that and
actually talking about doing the videos
that was the hardest thing for me to get
used to
yeah was just walk on the street and
knowing there's somebody coming up again
I think it just comes from practice I
think people often you know you're here
you want to be here and you want to take
this big leap but it's too scary and
there's too many people who might judge
you and I find for most people to make
that leap it's like small steps small
steps small steps and in the first video
I did outside I did like making sure
those nobody around me and then the next
one you know there was somebody far in
the distance I tried to wrap it up
really quickly and then he heard me and
whine like okay I'm just gonna do it and
somebody was walking by me and some
people turn around and like what's
happening and some people don't care and
just go on with their lives but I think
just from practice you get the
incremental gains and with that practice
you stop caring as much about what other
people think and I agree I think if you
if you base your life based on other
people's opinions you're always going to
hold you hold yourself back and you
won't recognize your natural talents
yeah so the question of the day today is
a name one incident where you did worry
about others and how
did you get over thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso don't worry about what it's
getting it over to you Carlos Slim Helu
is that the name thank God my typing it
out Carlos okay okay